what my dog is ugly you're ugly you
don't have a profile picture johnny
green
get out of here
no insulting my [ __ ]
okay
okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel today i am
going to be reacting to the feminine
truth delete your instagram for him
before i start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos if you
have watched two or more of my videos
and you do not subscribe me you we have
beef
beef also this is my dog ellie she's
joining me today
okay
about instagram
[Music]
so why do you have instagram well i
think we all know as women you have
instagram to
get validation you want validation you
want to know you look good tallulah
i have instagram to make money
you wanted other guys to message you but
it's true that's true if a cat if a cute
guy messages me i would not be mad i
would not you want likes
you want um see if there's a better guy
out there maybe i don't know but is it
really sensible or respectful
to do this when you're already dating a
high value guy
once you are with him like this high
value guy
like you are his
that's just it like you are here okay
and this is what girls don't understand
when you are dating somebody somebody
you are a representation of him
you are so if you get your ass all over
instagram like that's embarrassing to a
guy like that's really embarrassing
because you're basically advertising and
saying
i'm like trying to get out of here
basically
you are not
anyone else's you are not out there in
the marketplace looking for the next
person right
you are you belong to him he belongs to
you you belong to him whatever way you
want to say it
and i think that this video really is
about explaining how
once you are with this high-value guy
what you should do with your instagram
and quite honestly there's nothing more
to say other than
in the bin it needs to go
it needs to go the reason i need to go
is because it is
look we all know as women that when we
post up a photo of ourselves
we like if i was to ask you
i'm a middle ground type of person
i do think that if it's a problem in
your relationship you should be willing
to delete a piece of social media
however i don't think every girl that
has instagram is like out there fishing
i think if you have instagram you should
be 100 comfortable
with him looking through your messages
you should not have anything on there
like in your messages
and you can even turn them off like you
can turn it off so you can't get
messages from anybody
so i don't know don't don't be doing
shady [ __ ] girls why are you posting
that photo of you up in this dress or
tight jeans or a bikini or whatever
you're going to say oh because i look
nice or oh because of this that the
other it's for me it's for me no it's
not for you and you know it's not for
you there's other people if it was for
you you'd be like they're taking photos
of yourself and that's it that's all
you'd need and you could just look at
them right like if you're dating like
some
low value guy that does nothing for you
in your life and that you're not even
happy with go ahead but realistically
just get rid of the guy and move forward
with your life but you know fine do it
but if you're someone who's a high value
guy and that and yeah if you're someone
who's a high-value guy and you are still
behaving this way
this guy is gonna like literally this
guy is gonna say to you like don't do
that or if you do or he might just leave
he might not even tell you that's the
thing like guys like that that have
options they're not gonna give you a
warning
they're just gonna leave again like i'm
gonna be gone
it is incredibly disrespectful like if i
was a guy and i had
a girl posting up all these photos of
herself like on nights out and like look
at me here and look at me and my tight
jeans and my bikini and it's the same
thing like i would want to date a guy
that's posting gym selfies all the time
like it's it's the same equivalent i
that would not no no sir no this new
surgery i've had or whatever it is
then i would feel i would i would it's
literally as if like we're watching our
partner go and take another girl out for
a meal that's pretty much it
like or our like partner like standing
in the believe the street and say
like look at all this money i have look
at this house i have anyone want to come
spend some time with me that's what
you're doing on instagram yeah that's so
true you ever see a girl like posting an
ass pic
and no pictures of her it's her
boyfriend i'm like
ladies what are we what are we doing
and i know what you're thinking oh i
won't just won't post like pictures of
me in my bikini anymore
yeah 100
do not do that like that is that is just
not okay like at all it's not okay in
general to be honest as a woman posting
up photos in your bikini unless you have
a really really valid reason that you're
like a catwalk model and when i say
model i'm not talking about instagram
model and talking about sponsorship
deals and i'm not talking about any fans
right you're you're with him you should
be proud to be with him
you know and
quite honestly i think it's either a
case of like completely deleting your
instagram like that's the best thing you
could do like that's going to show that
you have respect for your partner that
like you are all about him right
or
you just don't post things is my youtube
channel a red flag i think it is
just don't post photos of yourself like
you can post a photo of you guys that's
fine or like i don't know your like cat
or something but you're not gonna do
that like i've seen what you guys are
like you're not gonna do that you're
gonna keep posting up photos of like
looking in the camera in a certain way
we've all done it though right like i'm
100 guilty as well
but when you're with someone especially
someone that is
high value that is you know incredibly
um protective over his women it's really
really disrespectful
to happy posting up this kind of content
these types of guys if they if you
continue to do that and they say to you
i don't want you to do that anymore and
you say and you're lucky you got a
warning to be honest most guys if they
see you i won't say most guys any guy
that has options and doesn't feel like
he has to date that like
he's just gonna leave he's not even
gonna tell you why
they're just going to leave you
and then what you're going to do when we
start with your little instagram
attracting low value guys and we all
know the ones right we have
like we have guys in our direct messages
all the time all the time and half time
we don't even read them right like we're
just not even reading them i do not get
that many messages i'm not even gonna
lie i get a couple
here and there but it is not as crazy as
some girls you are gonna lose
this guy
this high value guy that makes you feel
great
over your instagram yeah
it's just not worth it like if you have
a guy that you really really love and
want to spend the rest of your life with
is is instagram worth it it's not even
that good of an app to be honest like
tick tock is way more fun and you'll
just be left alone with your phone in
your instagram in your pajamas
wasting your best years
so that's just my little take on that i
don't think it's i don't think
instagram's the way forward for you
especially if you've got if you've got a
high value guy in your life anyway if
you don't agree or you agree
please like and subscribe leave it in
the comments
okay guys you should go subscribe to her
channel she's almost at a thousand subs
let's get her monetized let's get her
monetized okay
all right guys do not forget to
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification bell
and i will talk to you guys next time